Apparently when I was five years old,
I told my mother that I was tired
of her wanting me to be a doctor
and that I was going to MIT
to be an astrophysicist
because I really thought
that I would be seeking out the truth,
the truth in physics,
you know, the origins of the universe,
the laws by which all of existence exists,
and that's really what I wanted to do.
I wanted to do physics or astrophysics,
either I wanted to do atomic, subatomic physics
or astrophysics.
But I think it's because that my mother
had taken me to the omnitheater planetarium
at the Museum of Science,
and I was extremely impacted by that visit,
and I was fascinated by black holes.
And I really wanted to know if there were white holes,
like, if you went through a black hole,
what happened?
I remember for some reason
that question just completely fascinated me
when I was young.
So, astrophysics.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.